I can't hold it completely like
sometimes it'll go away and then I can
it'll come back and then I have to
sneeze what about your farts you're
holding your farts no of course not
that's not healthy you shouldn't do that
you get indigestion yeah yeah
[Music]
does anybody know somebody or I know you
ever I know people yeah we know we know
we know people answering all fast people
don't mutual people eat this show
sometimes I just met you so I sort of
know you I kind of know people and I
think we're all in each other's circle
now you know is that what you wanted I
guess I know that's exactly where I was
going with this I know I know dancers I
know a lot of dancers does it count if
they don't know me back yeah yeah it
counts it's just about you knowing it so
it's parasocial okay we know people is
that the article that's what it's about
do you know people
yeah I'll do that sometimes it hurts to
see people do that
it looks so unsatisfying Anthony what
are you gonna say should I Google my
symptoms no let's keep on talking about
the the joy of holding it why do you
hold it in
um it depends on like the setting like
maybe it's uh
they're just doing the Reeboks
like maybe it's like a this type of
setting I don't want to sneeze and ruin
a moment you could go like this and hold
your dolls and sneeze out your mouth
like that it's actually possible for you
to hold it I feel like it's impossible
for me I can't hold it completely like
sometimes it'll go away and then I can
it'll come back and then I have to
sneeze what about your farts you're
holding your farts no of course not
that's not healthy you shouldn't do that
you should get indigestion yeah
how about like when you sneeze like this
and then you like wipe it on yourself
this food was nice bro that's true oh
man
I sneeze without snot
particles it's moisture particles but
it's not like full-on like stringy
booger yeah but I mean it's still coming
out at 100 miles an hour so you block it
you go with your hands yeah you go like
that am I when I'm in my house I'll go
on to sneeze it feels great you go and
then just boogers flying all over your
couch yeah you don't do that inside your
shirt that's a good move don't do the
antifa well she doesn't have a shirt to
do it with no I do this I do this I love
this
oh sorry yeah and then I do it
you sneeze on a friend yeah yeah
we know each other
then this
yeah I would also rather do that but
there's this dude who uh injured his
throat and blew a hole in it Jesus
Christ after holding in a sneeze that's
his excuse he was just deep throwing the
man that's exactly what it said here
I think we got to the bottom he got
caught he's at the doctors and then
they're like what's wrong with your
throat oh my uh how did my sneeze and
the doctor said no you were just deep
throating a man yeah because you were
[__] sounds like a doctor
don't worry I got the perfect thing for
that he's like yeah bro I know you're
sucking dick Shut up I know those throat
bruises when I see him like sure I don't
want to sneeze he says he's writing in
the chart he's like I almost feel like
[__] if you're really telling the truth
that the doctor's like I know you suck a
dick
feel like doctors do that anyway yeah so
this guy was um he tried to Halt a
sneeze by pinching the nose and holding
his mouth closed
try that you know what's crazy that does
that does mess you up for sure oh does
he think it's gonna come out of here
that's what I had to do I had to go to
the hospital because I did that what did
you do one time on the way to Vegas my
ears were popping so I try to like you
know you like too much pressure right
yeah too much pressure so I was doing
that really hard and something went
extra pop and then uh I had to go to the
hospital I'm like are you scared fix my
eardrum you popped
no I didn't pop it or did you like push
it out almost like a sphincter like a
hernia I don't know exactly what
happened but something happened to it
and it like instantly got infected oh
[__] it's like a weird thing yeah so
then I had to go and that's the first
time I took Vicodin there you go it was
a doctor like now he's addicted you need
to let you need to stop letting your
boyfriend yeah
yeah I know what it was yeah yeah so
this guy started to have strange
symptoms including painful swallowing a
change in his voice and a popping
sensation and swelling in his neck
sounds like dick to me sounds like
sucking dick doctor said that streaks of
air had become trapped in some of his
throat tissue including semen and it
rubbed her yeah oh there you go holy
[__] it said that on so spontaneous
rupture of the pharynx is very rare
usually caused by vomiting to wretching
heavy coughing some kind of trauma and
dick sucking and holding sneezes now I
guess yeah that's a [__] up I'm not in
a lot of situations where I do have to
hold it so then like like even holding
my pee and stuff like that so then I
think my tolerance got weaker like you
know when you're in school or like
always at the offer like in places where
you're just like oh you can't let a rip
yeah then you're like you you build a
muscle for it you know that's why you
gotta always hold it you gotta always
try to practice to hold it really I
don't know because I I definitely lost
the ability that it's like oh I got a
fart and like I'm in public but I'm like
hey do you guys have loud farts or do
you have silent farts oh predominantly
silent silent silent
customers waiting for the drink you're
like
you know what I tried to do sometimes
this is this is I don't know if you guys
tell me if you do this but sometimes I
like to challenge myself when I'm
farting and I notice like it's like a
big one I'll try to like release it
slowly oh yeah yeah me too for sure to
let it go
and there's a little Challenge and I
just go oh still got it it's like when
you got like a [__] bottle of soda
that was taken and you gotta like I'm a
firm believer if you got a little you
gotta let a little air out I had this
one black homie who had the funniest
thing have you ever had a friend who
would like uh shake his ass cheek while
he farts and it goes
no never I've never had a homie who
shook his ass I could never remember to
do that because like by the time I
remember it's already in the past yeah
yeah but this fool would remember every
time he would grab his ass cheek and he
would he would shake it like this so the
air the opening goes like that and then
when he farts it goes
yeah
I want to hear what this sounds like
yeah I'm not I don't keep in touch with
him anymore so I gotta try it I got like
95 of my farts are silent really yeah
but are they violent yeah
yeah I'm always I'm always spreading
them yeah I do that I do that that is
insurance though if you don't want it to
sound
spread it you just have to like shift
over yeah and then it'll go
I do that when my wife is sleeping and
I'm peeing in the morning sometimes I'm
like I gotta fart so I spread the cheeks
spread the Geeks yeah yeah I want to be
loud yeah you don't want to you don't
want to cause a scene yeah make her
throw up in the middle of her just go
like this like let's open it up a little
bit yep yeah I go in the mirror and I
look back at it you don't even need your
hands right you already got the
right you got the friction of the
section of the seat that's what I'm
standing up bro sometimes I'm at the gym
and I have my music playing in my
headphones and I don't realize that
other people who can hear
loud so if I'm like on the treadmill I
know my card is loud but I know No One's
Gonna Hear except the music cuts off at
that opportune time yeah but when the
music's in your headphones you think
everyone else is like hearing what you
hear so yeah that's true
and I'm like oh they probably heard it
how do you guys feel about people
burping in public I don't like that I
don't care but and um but my girl um she
you know she's the one that was like oh
that was a burp and I was like oh it
it's a it's a you know it bothers you
you know so it's a sort of it's like a
it's like an interesting thing like
because now you're self-conscious I'm
like oh I don't know you're like you
could burp around me but I guess I don't
like what it smells bro yeah when it
smells it's like all right what are we
doing if it's just a sound yeah if it's
if it's a burp and it's funny and it's
loud that's cool but sometimes people
will burp and then you smell it you're
like all right I think it's rude in a
restaurant I wouldn't do that yeah I
guess it's a setting but sometimes you
know you know sometimes it just happens
yeah with the boys it's a good time
my burps come out like I sound like I'm
forcing it I don't even know how to do
one that's one so like it just comes
yeah sometimes it just happens you're
like oh excuse me yeah but it's not like
one of those really loud oh yeah no no
no no like you know when you're forcing
it out and you're like
no yeah like Homer Simpson do you
remember
um how Lizzy Rasputin could burp like a
like a huge gigantic belt yeah I do
remember that yeah you know sometimes
like some people know how to burp like
just massively on command yeah and she
was like a you know like a pretty little
blonde girl and you would never expect
it and then her you mean like this
and then one time like so we know she
could do that for like years it's like
one of her like party trick things and
then uh once Victor was dating her he
was like I hate that she does that and
you like I think she stopped because of
him
[Laughter]
she just did it because it was funny you
could picture that right
everybody loved that she did it we
thought it was the greatest it's a fun
party trick but then like once it's your
man and like probably the you know it's
not funny yeah but you know if you're
getting mad at your girl for doing that
you're kind of lame
that's true it's like What's your deal
bro it's a fun time it gets laughs
it's like what's the look if it smells
like [__] then it's like all right
that's a problem like okay that's you
should see a doctor but if it's no smell
and it just like she could because some
people you see them like suck air into
their belly I think that's how she does
it you suck air in and you belch that's
a good point you guys the command nope
I was like another one do you like gold
first
oh he could do it we wanted to I just
don't know how there's there's
definitely a moment where it's like uh a
pocket of air just goes in and then it
just sits here for a second then just
comes back up can't do it how do you go
look at Nick trying though yeah I'm
trying dude that's a dick sucking yeah
can you do that one more time yeah yeah
like that uh but yeah when I'm now that
I'm around it and someone that can
actually do it it's actually way cooler
and it's Lamer that he was mad about
it's even doubled it's cool when you can
do it right yeah it's a it is a talent
you know yeah when you no she needs to
stay a pretty little white girl nah dude
like if you're farting around town
that's weird you know like if you could
fart up a man like I just farting on
command is way weirder yeah it's a
little weird where's that coming from
yeah yeah you're sucking up the air
first
that's talented but is that funny that's
funny with your [__] first yeah but
if you're a girl like imagine you were
dating a girl and then she like her like
special party trick because she could
fart on command then I can see how
people would be like all right dude like
can we not do that can you stop doing
that please more like or like queef on
command
when
[Laughter]
I would just question her her practice
like how did she get there yeah how'd
you get there yeah all right guys
comment below if you could queef on
command yeah comment below what bodily
thing you can do on command and why your
your boyfriend hates you boy that's
engagement baby
[Music]
foreign